io io mi dovete togliere lo zoom della
videocamera io non c'è non sono abituato
lo userò fino alla mia morte
bene tutti ragazzi venuti a questo video
e sono fa vj non so se vi ricordate i
giochi in stick men quelli con erin
stickman che anni anni fa facevo sul
canale che andavano tantissimo tanto che
un sacco di gente ci ha fatto delle
playlist ipo giochi con sigman favi jvc
rolo maestro che se clicchi ha prevenuto
ci sono tutti i video avevo fatto tra
cui 1 2 35 quinto bud spencer e terence
hill
va bene comunque non fermiamoci su
questo volevo dirvi che esiste un gioco
di ieri stigma che ancora non avevo
fatto
volevo riportarli tutti perché li ho
giocati secoli fa uno non me li ricordo
fortunatamente sono pero cambiato quindi
i giochi belli li volevo riportare ci
può credere anzi quindi farò anche gli
altri però volevo iniziare da questo che
ancora non avevo proprio fatto che si
chiama breaking the bank quindi play che
mi ricordo di averlo fatto breaking the
bank perché non c'è tra tutti
chissenefrega tanto non me ne ricordo
neanche uno quindi di farli farò tutti
questo qua non mi dicono solo fatto chi
se ne frega perché tanto sono ricorda
come solo giocassi per la prima volta le
sgrò allora devo entrare nella banca io
sono harry in stick ma si chiama così il
tizio è la sua avventura è molto lunga
diviso in capitoli che poi vedremo la
prima l'entrata in banca ci sarebbe
questa non è l'entrata solita ma devo
utilizzare un oggetto particolare a casa
una serie io per entrare in banca un
tunnel potrebbe essere carina
con l'effetto sonori di zelda ha un non
so che di fantastico
minecraft di scavi sotto i piedi e non
dovresti mai farlo proprio per questo
motivo qua mi piacciono i treni molto
bene non era quello giusto mista
cambiamo facciamo il travestimento mi
trasferisco da da sacco di soldi in
mezzo alla strada tra l'altro lo
guardavi ho dimenticato un sacco di
soldi che strano ma veramente ma siete
pazzi ha funzionato stack agata fois va
bene siamo dentro ha funzionato non so
come va bene bene siamo entrati in
disguise era veramente questo io
forse non era questo lo so qui non era
questo porca vacca con sé ma no come
potermi rifare fatemi di scegliere può
farmi di scegliere non mi mettere i
crediti di mortacci tua davanti non era
tunnel non era disguise facciamo a chi
minh l'altro che farà la demolizione sia
la scelta giusta almeno è una cosa che
non si sente inosservata molto ninja
vice cosa mi dice che sia perfetto
sei veramente un lupin coi fiocchi laser
drill ragazzi sto provando tutte manco
all'inizio disco partire o questa mi
sembra abbastanza easy non te la far
cadere addosso ragazzi c'è un problema
di fondo mancano ne mancano due del
trasporto esplosione uno dei due
esplosione del teletrasporto spero di
nomi che mi dentro sport e chissà dove
era teletrasporto molto bene
teletrasporto bene siamo partiti da dio
le prime 5 o mancate zucche che non
porterà quello che non avrei mai messo
mai
ma qual è allora quale di questi era a
non è nessuno di questi alla fine ti
sbagli a prescindere ecco perché mi
sembra strano che vediamo gli sbadati
tutti mi sembra strano di non averlo
ancora fatto ecco perché facciamogli
skype in the prison non so cosa dirvi
non ho mai fatto le breaking the bang
peccato perché non puoi entrare nella
banca dati fx e skype in the prison è il
primo serio insomma quella
dall'introduzione dopo aver tentato di
entrare in banca ovviamente il nostro
harry stickman è stato beccato e messo
in prigione
posso andare
che simpatico che il servizio una torta
una torta dentro il pacco a ok mi posso
scegliere il modo per evadere di
prigione va bene allora stavolta non
facciamo cagate a passo decidere cosa
aprire se la finestra o la portafinestra
però immagino che sia veramente alta la
prigione quindi forse ho sbagliato non
avevo dubbi di questa beffa fallo sulla
porta alla sua porta per chi chiama
inviato un pacco con le cose per evadere
spiegatevi può stare attento applicarle
cosa ragano ministra non mi distrarrò
mai dall'inizio del gameplay fino alla
fine pur o2 dall'alto
no
perfetto ok cintura di granate o sedia
cintura di granate voglio vedere cosa
succede ma sono un genio rega di è di
utilizzare la sedia questa volta che
dite bandiamo sopra via sinistra destra
destra o ci sarà una volta in cui
azzeccherà una cosa giusta no non
saltare non sa dare ok ok scelgo io cosa
fare bisogna usare la rock lunghi
bloggers perfetto vai prova beh vedo che
sono funzionali in realtà ce l'ho fatta
programmato azzeccato la prima signori
vuota player tra i four a different
henning ok acidi sono altri ending ce
l'ho fatta propria volta ce l'ho fatta
bene
prima non sia riuscito a fare niente
abbiamo perso della banca ho vinto
subito ben miracolo tutte e due le volte
avevano un'altra volta energy drink cosa
faceva nrg drink tra l'altro la madonna
il prima che se gli sempre rinchiuso
come fa a no
la madre cosa è successo qua sono
praticamente velocissimo e gli altri
sono tutti i lenti
[Musica]
beh simpatica la faccenda perché non era
neanche così difficile evadere di
prigione nota basta mettere energy drink
subito ho finito ho già vinto vabbè
stato poi a ben venuto un infarto
beh quello è un problema sono evaso ma
con l'infarto va bene facciamo teleport
e quando vi porta stavolta fuori
beh col cambio che passa va beh direi di
fare e allora rocket launcher a questo
punto noi in ordine vai rocket launcher
e easy non ti far saltare in aria solo a
te stesso
va bene niente quello thriller sarebbe
l'escavatrice nel terreno
vabbè stato easy pensavo molto peggio
semmai il bagno o paci teito rock roll
bar o paci gator soli l'opacità ha perso
passare attraverso gli oggetti va bene a
fu anche al centro della terra mi sa
come l'opacità e torno voglio tantissimo
stavo scherzando ritrae facciamo crowbar
come se la sono inventata sta roba
dell'opacità ito c'erano una fantasia
incredibile salve amici
bravo carri add on schivarli o che sta
partendo mi è familiare
però non mi ricordo assolutamente come
si fa a ficcare dentro al muro
lui la madonna bravissimo di pd e vabbè
i treni sono aprendo allo sparare al
momento giusto
dov'è il tasto spara bravissimo ho
schiacciato il momento giusto ho vinto
io quindi si stanno pagando tutti sotto
fatto fiero attenzione però eh vabbè con
le donne volo stesso charme comunque sei
stato bravissimo è finito
oc bene va bene non so se c'erano altre
ending ma spero di no il pubblico va
bene mi è piaciuto tanto vabbè con cui
sarai schepp in the prison più breaking
the bank insieme li ho fatti volevo
ritrovarmi comunque tutti i quotidiani
stigma che sono tanti sotto i ponti ne
diamond exif rating airship di china
cosa diavolo ai big to china ragazzi
spero che vi sia piaciuto per adesso
concludo qua bellissimo un guerri stick
ma mi mancava un sacco fatemi sapere se
volete altri dinosauri sigman se no la
finisco qua io li rifarei tutti vi giuro
non mi ricordo niente per comunque c'è
la possibilità che io vecchi altre vie
che non avevo preso l'altra volta anzi
sicuramente come se vi è piaciuto
momento mi piace anche vari social
comunista descrizione come se siete voi
ci vediamo come sempre hanno seguito da
ragazzi
[Musica]